man there's so many great movies coming
out this summer it really feels like we
should do something special for this
episode kill just read the tale brother
I've already got the Snickers blizzard
from DQ in hand now we just need some
movie fans let's get out of here I want
to be with the people boy
[Music]
hey Mads
you want to go see a movie great I'm
already upset
cam you're on an episode a weekend
ticket what surprise today we're getting
out of the studio to surprise some
friends and this episode is brought to
you by DQ but you will be brought to the
movie theater and my movie ticket
giveaway trivia cano we look good next
to teal yeah let's go as it is summer
let's do some summer movie trivia okay
all right how many sequel slash
franchise films are coming out this
summer well there's like this whole
nineties resurgence coming out right now
so we got men in black and then we got
Toy Story and then we got Lion King
spider-man wait oh and then Hobbes and
Shaw I'm gonna go with 514 wait what I
give you miss child's play you went with
the whole 90s thing time for some toy
story questions
is Woody's love interest and what is her
occupation bopi and she heard she yep
yeah
time for another surprise look it's
Kunal wait Kunal coming with not very
serious
hey what's up guys what is this well
welcome to weekend ticket to trivia
Edition what is the name of Simba's
childhood lioness friends are ready so
the director of the new Lion King also
directed another Disney remake can you
name that remake yeah
one two three jungle boy nice who did
Hobbes work for and Fast & Furious Five
do you want to use a lifeline yeah how
about instead of phoning a friend we
pick one up hey Lee
[Music]
welcome to weekend ticket who did Hobbs
work for and his appearance in Fast Five
hey Hobbs was just the answer is
Diplomatic Security Service all right
you ready for another question we're
moving into Lion King territory how
often can boom be' clear the savanna
after every meal oh wow
nicely done how many years has it been
since the original The Lion King that is
correct
flawless what animals are new toys in
Toy Story for plush bunny okay what is
it duck duck and bunny work honey yeah
see that's 18 words almost thing you
guys are finishing each other's
[Music]
[Applause]
all right everyone you did it and to
celebrate I have for you three Fandango
movie tickets and DQ gift card there you
go there you go and you better hurry
because if CDs are already started oh no
no no no I asked if you wanted to go see
a movie oh and don't forget to get your
Blizzard after the movie see ya
why it just happens
[Music]
[Music]